[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning you've
probably heard about covet long-haulers
dealing with the health consequences of
the virus
well this morning we're highlighting
those suffering long-term economic pain
one full year after lockdowns forced
many companies to close
the share of unemployed americans who
have been out of work for more than half
a year
six months have surged above 40 percent
so we returned to a small business we
visited last year
at this time to see how those economic
long-haulers are coping
and to get a sense of the challenges
they face in returning to work
how are you doing it's been tough we
first met the annel
family last march just days after gabe
lost his job at a company that handles
lighting and sound for large
in-person events you know i mean i get
it this has never happened before
this has never happened before so it's
time to hunker down
as america went into lockdown stay home
neither gabe nor for that matter i could
imagine how long this pandemic would
last
can we go a year
it's crazy to ask yeah or how long he'd
be struggling to find work
yeah i've sent out resumes and spoken
with people
but nobody's hiring no one we're not my
industry is not moving now so it doesn't
matter you know
over the holidays this career audio
technician became a temporary ups
delivery man
at first it feels demoralizing you don't
want to tell anybody it feels
demoralizing but it's
because it's work and you know and so
disrespect for the people who are doing
that job
doesn't know what you were doing not at
all the first day it felt demoralizing
until a lot of people i met were in
similar industries as me
and it felt like you're you're everybody
else
not like yeah you know and it was
helpful it really helped
but it's clear more help is needed one
out of four small businesses actually
closed in 2020
and of those that remain over 40 percent
of owners believe
it'll take more than six months to
recover at corporate av
where gabe once worked how big of a
change have you seen year over year
pre-pandemic to right now we might be 25
percent
of what we would have been normally in
this time
owner joe gilderson says the pandemic
has shrunk his live event business
into a series of less profitable virtual
gatherings
some of which may become permanent do
you think
the in-person event business is going to
come back like it was
i don't think every event will come back
to being
hundreds of people together i think
certain events will probably stay online
it means that you can't fully heal from
this not quickly
and that means former employees like mo
johnson can't heal quickly either
i did have to ask for some extensions
here and there
we borrow for my 401k and a year without
full-time work
has meant a year without medical
coverage something we first discussed
last summer
my wife and i actually had a spat today
she said you know you should go to the
dentist and i'm like we don't have
insurance
lately he made another medical
compromise putting off the purchase of
new contact lenses
honestly i do need some more but i've
been really washing
cleaning and oh man but that's that's
dangerous man i know
disposable ones yeah knock on wood you
don't have an infection
yeah you gotta clean those things it's
only thanks to unemployment benefits and
federal stimulus money that former
full-time employees like mo johnson have
been able to keep up with their bills
this is a cushion to make your life a
little softer between now and when
things pick back
up well i i i don't call it a cushion
it's
it's hard earned i've paid into the
system all my life
you know this is what i pay in for
you're not giving me back my money
you're giving me back my investment when
we spoke a year ago
gabe's wife claudia feared that the
federal government wouldn't be there
when her family needed the help you're
just constantly worried about
like can i make this payment can i put
my kid
you know can i get a doctor even before
even before
but these days even after unexpected
expenses like a damaged fence and broken
appliances
she has a different outlook i don't feel
as skeptical
as i did last year because last year i
just really felt like wow we're just
going to be in an island you know
but this year i feel like okay i think
the government
is hearing us and trying to get
somewhere
how important has the coveted stimulus
been to keeping you guys afloat this
year
it's the only reason we're afloat one
full year into this pandemic
that's pretty much the goal for families
like the annelles
pay the rent or mortgage make at least
the minimum payments on your credit
cards
you may only be treading water but at
least you're not
going under we're not going to get out
of debt
at all but we can just you know ride the
waves
ride the waves for a little while longer
and that's the best most of us can hope
for
we do want to point out some positive
developments for the people in our story
both gabe and now
and mo johnson have recently been called
in for part-time work at corporate av
that's that audio company they're part
of
and when we were there last week owner
joe gilderson received his very first
two phone calls for live events
being scheduled for the fall these were
ones that had been canceled in 2020.
however he does predict it will be a
slow ramp up and it's likely that not
everyone will be hired back
all at once he had to lay off more than
a dozen people yeah
so moved by gabe's vulnerability yes so
from
feeling demoralized to feeling grateful
and just trying to hold on and
ride the wave and mo saying you know i
built i put money in
that's not a cushion i put out a handout
yeah that's his investment it's his part
of the american drill and the difference
that
that money has made for people it's
really literally as you say just it's
kept them above water
absolutely i like both of them thank you
tony i like them too